[Music]
this week on
forward calling people conspiracy
theories is not helpful agree these are
these are kind intelligent wonderful
people and if we say it's them versus US
it doesn't help us understand what's
going on uh and and we shouldn't we
shouldn't discount those people and we
shouldn't discount their theories part
of the story of these misbeliefs is that
it's about the belief in the outside
world in something that is ain't so but
it's also taking that as a central theme
in somebody's life and using that to
look at the world as their
[Music]
perspective it is my pleasure to Welcome
to the podcast psychologist and
behavioral economics professor from Duke
University bestselling author of
predictably irrational in his latest
book which we're going to discuss
misbelief what makes rational people
believe irrational things Dan arieli
welcome Dan my pleasure thanks so much
for having me uh I've been a fan of your
work for a long time I I read
predictably irrational before I quote
unquote knew who you
were there's obviously the TED Talks uh
you're one of the foremost thinkers on
why people behave quote unquote
irrationally um but this book I think
got very personal and it's something
that I was fascinated by because I've
been through a at least my own versions
of it um so you stumbled upon some
misinformation about yourself uh
including from people that actually knew
you were like hey Dan I didn't know that
you were uh doing such nefarious things
and then you were like what nefarious
things then you started digging into it
and it led you down a deep rabbit hole
that did result in this book yeah first
of all it was terribly
painful but you're very right to to
point out
that the the accusations for the people
who knew me was extra tough was um
something about it was extra tough and
by the way it doesn't
stop it started in early covid days we
are now toward the end of
23 um last week my University got a
letter that was so threatening that I
had to take it to the
authorities and um and about a month ago
there was a new video out there
connecting me to the massacre of October
7th uh not true by the way if if you're
curious but it's also true that this
book um is very different from my other
ones the the other books I had some
research that I've done and I felt it
might be useful for people and I I wrote
it for this
purpose this
one it was a mystery that hit me like a
like a wall and I I had to kind of try
and and find out what was going on and
and the story was that Co for me I
felt it was in some way the the height
of my
career it was obviously a problem with
the health and a virus but it was also a
social science problem and I started
getting lots and lots of questions about
it all kinds of people wanted to know
what to do should the police give fines
or not fines big fines or not how do we
get do distant education distant
learning what do we do with domestic
violence a number of questions were
incredible and I stopped everything else
and I felt I was just being as useful as
as I could and then at some point in
July I get an email that says dan what
happened to you how have you changed and
very quickly I say how have I changed
and I get a long list of
links one of them for example describes
how I got badly burned true most of my
body is covered with scars including the
right side of my face that's why I don't
have hair on this side it described how
I spent three years in hospital and then
it went on to say that because of my
injury I started hating healthy people
and that's why I joined the cabal and
Bill Gat and the Illuminati to try and
kill as many healthy people as possible
and and I spent about a month trying to
argue with these
people um I think I I want to I wanted
to dig into this for a second Dan
because um I I and people I know who had
a had a similar Instinct so the thought
is look some people are misinformed and
if I could just spend a little bit of
time with them I could let them know
look you got it all wrong and I'm
actually a reasonable person and they
would see that they were mistaken and
then they would say oh wow like having
spoken to Dan clearly uh he's not a
member of the Illuminati trying to you
know reduce human life you
know so that that's the Instinct one has
that's that's the Instinct right but but
look let me give you another perspective
um how old are you uh
48 okay in your 48 years how many people
have you convinced that they were
wrong you know more more than some
others danad but fewer than I'd like
okay but but I think I think we we all
admit that the number is not very high
that that we on one hand what you said
is so tempting to say if people only
knew the truth they would change their
mind on the other hand we have this
lifelong experience of Almost Never
managing to convince anybody but but we
still have this Instinct that if people
only knew the truth and and I certainly
believe that very strongly and I also
have personal information about me so
you know people
said I happen to know I'm not a member
of the
Illuminati or or more specifically I
could say look on Wednesday I was in
here's my calendar I was in a different
place I even offered somebody to look at
my tax returns to prove to them
that anyway
um there is a level of craziness where
it's about you that is different like if
you meet somebody and they say oh you
know I believe the Earth is flat and you
say I don't think so and you have a go
okay but when somebody tells you
something about
you and you're an expert on you and you
have your calendar and you have your
emails and you have your bank accounts
and you can prove to them and they're
still not convinced
that's a level of realizing that the
world is really really
odd right because I knew people believed
all kinds of things I don't believe in
but this this conflict between I'm an
expert on me and I have a lot of data
you know nothing about me and you have
lots of beliefs and I'm unable to move
you I tried for a month I met people
face to face I called people I joined
online discussion groups I joined
telegram all kinds of
things I sort of convinced one person
but was pitiful
pitiful one one one out of how many oh
thousands probably I mean you know lots
of discussion this woman by the
way uh the one I I sort of managed to
convince um she she gave me she talked
to me about all kinds of statistics of
people dying from covid these was the
early days and you know quarantine
basically reduced death and not only
they reduced death from Co they reduced
death from other
things as well no car accidents for
example but anyway we talked about this
and I said look I I am not just thinking
about the the people who are dead I also
think about the people who are sick and
I said I'm thinking about the people who
are
ventilators and and she said why are you
thinking and I said you know I I
remember being on one
I remember the the the the the
hopelessness of coming in and out
of
comma while
being
ventilated very very tough feeling and
as I was describing it to her I just
started crying I was I was thinking
about the people who are suffering right
now I was thinking about myself in my
early days in in hospital and I think
she she decided I wasn't as
evil
ER this way but but she still
um didn't fully trust me anyway I I
really failed and I'm a slow learner so
it took me a month of failing and then I
I said I have to understand this it was
like it was like one of it's like it's
an unbelievable puzzle well and it it's
super important today because uh the the
conspiracy theorist gets thrown around a
lot um nowadays but but but the fact is
that there are a lot of people who and
you point this out in your book uh just
are losing faith or losing trust in
various institutions and so in a low
trust environment it's easy to be
skeptical uh easier to frankly believe
the worst of someone uh even if it's
based on
nothing so um so so it's one reason why
your book is I think very timely and
very important is that you break down uh
why people believe something that may or
may not be right uh and you do it in a
non-judgmental way in like a human way
where you suggest like look like we're
actually kind of uh wired um for some of
these things uh for example social proof
like people are susceptible to that uh
you know based upon either a correct or
incorrect belief uh and Studies have
borne that out um so you break down the
reasons why people can be prone to
believing something that's not true and
and you have four categories uh where
you start with the emotional which I
completely agreed with and and believe
in and you even cite some of the same
mindset of scarcity studies uh that that
affected me with the suggestion that if
you stress people out um maybe either
economically or socially or in the case
of the
pandemic via isolation or uh you know
real world stress that they become prone
to uh believing certain things so so
first of all I I do want to emphasize
this um this idea that calling people
conspiracy theories is not helpful I
agree these are these are kind
intelligent wonderful people and if we
say it's them versus US it it doesn't
help us understand what's going on H and
and we shouldn't we shouldn't discount
those people and we shouldn't discount
their theories in the sense that they
fulfill a real need I mean it's not the
the way I would like them to fulfill
those needs but what what happen is that
people do feel
stressed and it's not the stress of oh
my goodness my calendar is too packed
it's the stress of I don't understand
the world what is happening here and you
know we've had a lot of it we have a lot
of it you know I I
I was shocked by how many college
undergrads are terrified of chat
GPT you know they're saying AR isn't
everything we're studying going to be
replaced what jobs will be there uh the
war in Ukraine you know what's happening
in Iran in the Middle East you know
there's lots of things that I I think
are understandably
stressful and and stress gets our brains
to want to find the story one one
example I very quickly bring in the book
is a question of two tribes of
fishermen one that fishes in the lake
and one that fishes in a deep ocean when
you ask the question which one of them
has a less predictable fishing life of
course the deep ocean has you know
currents and storms and so
on which one of them has more
superstitions the ocean
why because when things are not
explained we need a story doesn't have
to be true but it needs a story so when
people are stressed they want a story
but in our case they want a story about
a villain they want to blame somebody
else and they want a story that would
give them
superiority and finding a story with the
villain that is complex give them a
sense that they know something that the
rest of society doesn't
so you know we um poke fun it's people
who believe you know whatever and then
they say oh you making fun of me I am
the one who really understand what's
going on here it's really this whole
thing with the cabal and so on and you
just don't understand right because um
and and that by the
way again it's it's a perfectly
understandable way to to plug the hole
of saying I'm stressed out and I want
the story
yeah and now now you have a story not
not a great story but but you have a you
have a story that helps you temporarily
feel better so the moment you find out
that you know it's Bill Gates in the
Illuminati or whatever you say okay I'm
I'm relaxed it's not me and I understand
the
world but but that notion of being
relaxed only last a short time because
now you start saying oh my goodness what
else are they doing to us and then you
go online and you find out worse and
worse and worse
things hey YouTube thanks for watching
please do hit like And subscribe and hit
that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops probably
on Mondays but hit that Bell and thank
you you've started to touch on the
second uh set of factors which is
cognitive um there so there first
there's an emotional appeal to having a
bad guy uh having uh an Insider body of
knowledge that you're privy to uh and
then there there's also a cognitive
appeal that's in some ways related yeah
and the cognitive appeals are there are
multiple ones one of them is of course
which news are you
watching are you watching Fox News or
NBC I mean there's a there's a
choice on which one the the second one
is our unbelievable ability uh to to
bend to bend facts to our
will you can hear one thing and
completely discounted because it doesn't
fit with your idea you can ear something
else that has three points one is in
your favor two are against and you
discount those
and pay attention to that and then the
last component is our
overconfidence in our
knowledge and and there's a couple of
mechanisms there but they the one I like
the most um is is called the illusion of
explanatory depth and the way I
demonstrated it is I asked people if
they understand how a flush toilet
works you know one of those things and
people said yes and I said great on a
scale from 1 to seven they said I'm
great I said wonderful luckily for you I
have all the pieces of a flash toilet
here why don't you assemble it and of
course nobody can assemble it and then I
come back to them and I say okay so how
much do you understand it and people say
not so
much now if you think about it usually
when we argue with people we confront
them we we fight here's this information
here's this information you're not
hearing me there's another paper on this
and there's another fact on this and
what do you do with this
and and we know that people don't really
listen they start counterarguing even
before we finish the
sentence right and and we do the same we
don't listen to them and we start C argu
before they finish we we are basically
in a very defensive
mode and as a consequence sometimes we
finish arguments and even though we were
exposed to new information we're even
more sure about our original opinion
because we kept on rehearsing and and
thinking of supporting evidence
the the approach based on the illusion
of explanatory depth is to say don't
fight somebody come at it from their
perspective so for example think about
the elections in the
US lots of people think that the
elections were stolen and you can try
and argue with them stolen not stolen
here's evidence here and there or you
could say okay let's not argue whether
it was stolen help me understand how
exactly it was stolen
and how do elections actually work uh
how do the votes get counted and if
somebody wanted to steal the election
what could they do like how how would it
actually work like let's get into the
details and it turns out that when
people get to the details like the flash
toilet they say okay you know I'm not so
sure and and part of the story of these
misbeliefs is that it's about the belief
in the outside world in something that
is ain't so
but it's also taking that as a central
theme in somebody's life and using that
to look at the world as their
perspective right so so the moment we
reduce people from a 100% certainty to
95 we already are in a different world
because now they can't take it as a
central tenant in their in their
perspective and they start looking at
the world in a
maybe and that's a that's a huge step
forward
so so on the cognitive side you know
there ways to fight all of the all of
the cognitive Parts but but this one is
is the most interesting one and one that
we can
actually start
practicing the toilet is a good example
I don't think I could put the toilet
together um and and I might have though
I you know I probably wouldn't have
given myself a seven before the fact
though because I'd be like I don't know
um so there works on lots of things you
can ask people do they understand how
viruses work and locks and zippers and
so
[Laughter]
on it it works on lots of things but you
know in the the modern
workplace currently the way I see it
people are saying don't have any
discussions about touchy
topics but that's actually not that
good because you know we we where would
we talk about touchy topics where would
we get exposed to opinions that are
people that we respect you know if if
yeah that you kind of are forced to to
um be collegial to because they're
literally your colleagues um so there's
a quote from your book that speaks to um
the this approach the first thing to
understand is that the real issue is not
the facts allegations and stories the
real issue is emotional simply
acknowledging where they're coming from
and empathizing with their pain without
trying to correct them goes a long way
yeah a woman actually wrote to me today
about that that
quote and she said that she was deeply
offended by some of her friend statement
on on X on
Twitter and she called her friend and
she realized that her friend was as
upset with her about
that and um she basically said let's not
talk about the statements we made first
let's just remind each other that we're
friends that we care about each other
you know let's let's let's work from a a
perspective of initial trust and
compassion to the other person's
perspective and and you know they still
don't agree but it's a very different
kind of disagreement and they each see
why the way they phrase things were
offensive but it's um yeah this idea of
being on the on the
defense and and arguing about moral
grounds
it's
a it's it's it's incredible it's very
unhelpful because it's often a
discussion about something that happened
in the
past it's holding us from moving forward
you know the question of who was more
wrong is is usually not the not the
helpful way to move
forward
this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn going online without
expressvpn is like changing while
leaving your window wide open gross you
might not have anything to hide but why
give random creeps a chance to invade
your privacy that's why I use expressvpn
it's super easy you hit a button and
then you just beam in best of all you
know no one can see what you're doing no
big tech companies no ad companies no
other companies I use expressvpn when
you go online it is just you and your
surfing no one can see it you know it's
the way to go because a bunch of big
companies say hey all of you high-end
consultants and spies use
expressvpn secure your online activity
by visiting expressvpn.com slang today
that's
EXs
vpn.com yangang and you can get an extra
3 months free
expressvpn.com
yeah you know if you respect someone's
Humanity first and foremost and then
that their point of view in a particular
issue can become secondary pretty
quickly because like I mean who's going
to agree on everything is has always
been my my my um attitude and then I
focus on what what actually can be done
so the the the Third set of elements
that I I thought was really interesting
was uh personality and that there are
some personality types that might be a
little bit more susceptible or prone or
likely to believe something that might
not be born out uh and you mentioned
Superstition earlier um one of the
personality elements is p is seeing
patterns in things that may not actually
have patterns so so the one important
caveat to say about personality is that
it does lubricate the path toward
misbelief but it's not
deterministic right if we say stress is
the breathing ground for Mis beliefs
without stress you wouldn't get it if
people are just happy as clam like no
misbelief so you need
stress personality is not like stress
it's not like if you have it you get it
and if you don't you don't but there are
some personality type that do make it
easier to go down that that path and
they're not all bad traits for example
patternicity is the ability to see
patterns even ones that don't exist
there and don't exist and you can say oh
my goodness this could be really amazing
for artists to observe new things and
this could be amazing for scientists to
create new hypothesis and see things
that other people have not observed
before all of that is true it also has a
potential downside is that people are
able to see connection between you know
me and Gates and and so
on so so for just just as an example um
The Gates Foundation funded an
event a few months before covid to do a
simulation of uh pandemic which which
Gates has been warning about for years
that's right and they use covid as the
example now they funded lots of
simulations of lots of other things and
lots of time but but if you say here are
just two points that I'm looking at and
I'm ignoring everything else you say oh
my goodness how could it be that October
they knew that this will happen in
January and now now you you look at
other things that support this View and
and you build it so that's one of them
another one that is interesting is that
people who trust their
intuition to a higher degree are more
likely to go down the The Funnel of of
misbelief so people who have an
inclination I know what's really
happening here and I'm always right so I
trust myself the people who question
themselves are less likely to go down
this this path and actually you know one
of the things that I think that we don't
teach enough is this ability to hold
multiple hypothesis in mind you know the
the scientific
Pursuit is supposed to be the enjoying
the
path of moving from not knowing to to
knowing and it's a path that take years
right here's an experiment I want to do
it's never that I'll have an answer
tomorrow it will take a really long time
and it's a it's like an onion and we'll
pill different levels and we'll find out
something and so on and in the
scientific um process we we teach our
students to
enjoy marinate in the process of not
knowing
and enjoy the the slow figuring out of
what might actually happening now as
human beings we're very driven to not
keep uncertainty alive all the time we
want to know we want to know so but I
think we we all need to get a better
dose of this not just tolerating
ambiguity but learning to enjoy it
that's kind of the high level maybe
maybe that's what the
you know the Buddha would have wanted
from us right to basically say a a high
level of this is to is to basically say
I don't know I want to know but it will
take a long time and we'll never know it
100% but we'll we'll practice we'll get
closer and closer
that's that's a very tough mindset hey
hey Dan um I should know this but are
you married um I I'm divorced
actually well because the the way you
were saying this it reminded me of my
marriage where it's like oh uh you know
you can't be too confident in what you
think you know because you know your
wife might say the other thing and then
you're like well what did I know like I
thought we were doing this on Wednesday
but it turns out we are not you know you
know there's a lot there's a lot to
learn about ourselves from close
romantic
ties right where and it's a it's a great
analogy to to think about lots of things
that we we can learn from from where we
are to to what is what is happening we
can um understand like what are the cues
of
trust and we can think about what gives
us
resilience and we could talk about how
many times are we looking for the
truth and you know what what's happening
to to memory I mean there's just um is a
is a lens to look at other relationship
to look first because because romantic
life is so intense and we spend so much
time together and so intense it's
actually a very good starting point to
to think about other
relationships so you say okay let me
think about work relationships what
works what doesn't work you know start
with a very intense relationship at home
and and try to figure out what what are
the basics of relationship so it's a
it's a good it's a good starting point
you know some of the personality
research you cite um reminded me of
Jonathan Height's work um in terms of
there being certain personality traits
that correspond to being conservative or
liberal where if if you have uh High
disgust you have a high disgust reflex
you're more likely to be conservative if
you have a higher appetite for novelty
you're more likely to be liberal um and
and so you know when when people attack
each other in their political beliefs
there's part of me it's like you know I
mean you do realize like most of us
can't control our personality traits
that way and so you're kind of born with
a propensity so I feel like you're
attacking someone for something that is
kind of innate to them um do you have a
sense of that these traits that make one
more open to misbelief uh shall we say
um how prevalent are they uh uh
generally speaking you know so so first
of all I I I think that all of these
traits um have some kind of basis in
biology I think they have some basis in
Early Education I don't think it's all
what were you born right it's h it's
hard to separate from the environment
you grew up with in your early years
like propensity for discuss or novelty
you can imagine how early childhood
would have a big
influence on on the those things and I
think they have some leeway as well but
if you ask me like from the the 100%
piie of all the forces that get people
to become misbeliever what is the role
of
personality I would say it's probably
around 10 to
15% so so
substantial but but a a relatively small
part of the picture compared
to stress itive and I think that right
now uh after stress the biggest
component is the social
component happy holidays you know what's
tough to do during holiday season eat
right and not gain weight and not
frankly get a little extra tummy going
because you don't have time you're on
the go the way you can make it so you
stay healthy and charged up in the right
way is to use Factor America's number
one ready to eat meal delivery service
Chef prepared dietitian approved ready
to eat meals delivered straight to your
door this is the service that's going to
change your life I love their shredded
chicken taco bowl as just one example
it's not just for dinner and one thing
that's great about it is that it's
totally commitment free it's not one of
those things that's tricky you can turn
it on you can turn it off but you are
not going to want to turn it off because
it's going to change our life for the
better this December you can get factor
and enjoy eating well without the hassle
just choose your meals and enjoy fresh
flavor packed meals delivered straight
to your door ready in Just 2 minutes no
prep No Mess great for frankly the guys
who aren't going to be cooking for
themselves so well so head to factor
meals.com
50 and use code Yang 50 to get 50% off
that's code Yang 50 at factor meals.com
y50 to get 50% off try Factor
[Music]
today I I I would agree I think that
especially with social media that there
are massive communities that you're
joining uh you get a sense of belonging
uh again a sense of ingroup outg group a
sense of importance I mean a lot of
these folks develop significant
followings uh based upon uh you know
their questioning of certain things um
so bigger picture right now and and this
is what scares me deeply is that if you
were to oversimplify things you have
this
institutional uh point of view and then
you have the anti-institutional you're
all full of you're lying to me uh
that's fake
news Etc
um and the anti-institutional energy is
getting stronger and stronger uh because
people you know are losing faith in
various institutions and some of the
institutions haven't exactly done us a
massive solid by you know covering
themselves in glory that's right and and
think
about think about how quickly it is to
lose
trust right you one
experience of lost
Trust basically can color your your
point of view so so again imagine that
you have two people married and one of
them has a one night
stand and they come home and they say
honey I'm really sorry I had the one
night stand but we've been married for
10 years what's the probability will
happen again you know very very low that
that's not the case right the the case
is that one one bad
behavior um has a disproportional effect
right and and we basically say that that
the bad behavior is revealing something
truthful like the thing is you could be
really a bad person and trying to hide
it so when you act well I don't know if
I didn't catch you if you were just
hiding it but a bad action is is more
telling in terms of who you really
are so now you feel
betrayed and um you you saw the research
on the opioid epidemic and the influence
on elections yeah so with the opioid
epidemic you know lots of people said my
great aunt had a surgery and she came
back and they gave her these pills and
then she became an addict when she had
to start taking heroin and she died of
Overdose and you know they basically say
the system has failed
us the system has failed us now that's a
very big failing and I
they they could be correct in in saying
that but now they say our trust in the
government did not go from 100% to
90% saying oh you know what will happen
what are the chances that I'll have
another end with with a knee problem
that this will happen again they say no
I I've just lost drafts
completely in the in the government so
so one one bad
action has a disproportional negative
effect especially if we don't try to
recover the
trust so so yeah so you know and if if
somebody adopts the perspective of
misbelief and low
trust like the natural course of events
will not bring them up like just imagine
what would get P oh you know sorry about
all of that I trust you again like you
know it's not going to happen yeah yeah
it's a a
painstaking process uh so the social
proof I think be the most compelling
important Dynamic that people experience
in a way because I see people head down
certain roads all the time and then when
they gain um popular and energy they're
like oo like I'm I'm striking a cord
here and then they want to do more uh
and you know they get the endorphins and
the hits the likes um then and the rest
of it I think that drives a ton of
deeper behavior um it almost becomes
competitive too because then it's like
oh there's this other person over there
saying this like let's if I
can one up them in the absence of these
social rewards I think it would be much
less pronounced that's right and also
saying extreme
opinions right if you if you just stated
run-of the-mill average
perspective how many people would get
excited with what you're
saying you almost have to say things
that are on the verge of being
ridiculous
if you want to make a name for yourself
so so we have this not only are people
chasing you know social
credit but the way to get Social credit
is to say something extreme the the
silent majority counts for nothing right
if lots of people look at what you've
posted and no to themselves you feel
zero you know there's no there no
there's no improvement but what we're
really looking for is for those people
who would react and to get somebody to
react you need to do something something
extreme so it so it creates extremeness
but but not only
extremeness um there's also the the
issue of support and and you mentioned
that before and it's it's worthwhile
saying something about this so one of
the toughest things is being a
ostracized right being ostracized is a
tough feeling the world hates me or
people hate me and it affects people's
well-being and it affects people's
hopefulness for the future it affects
the willingness to donate money and it
it just has a big effect on on any kind
of pro-social behavior yeah you know you
did a study or you they did a brain uh
wiring study and it actually corresponds
to a sense of physical injury so it's
like not like oh it's in your head like
that being ostracized actually is
physically delerious yes it it it uses
similar brain mechanisms to physical
pain right which is which is uh which is
kind of
incredible um and and you know by the
way you can a lot of those things you
can say oh evolutionary I can see why
you would want that yeah because if
Society can ostracize somebody and it
will feel
painful then then it's a tremendous
Force to get people to
to act for the the the the total good
but but because of the ticism a lot of
these people turn to other
communities that basically give them the
love that they have lost yeah and you
know one one of the posts against me was
a post of somebody who described my
crimes against humanity he decided I was
the chief Consciousness architect of the
plan MC he predicted there will be
nurenberg trials
2.0 like the same way that they were
judging the crimes of Nazi Germany and
he predicted I would be found guilty and
his only question was whether I should
get life in prison or public hanging and
and about a thousand people responded
and the responses were so loving and
effusive to him like people
congratulated him on his writing style
and insight and depth and all kinds of
things lots of little hearts lots of
wonderful emojis and again in the same
way that we say that we don't want to
think that
these misbeliefs are for nothing also we
we don't want to think that this
tremendous social support is for nothing
it comes to fulfill a goal what is the
goal these people
feel lonely they feel ostracized they
feel
rejected and they they're the most
loving Community to each other it's kind
of amazing you know there there are so
some of those things are so hateful to
other people right they can they can
talk in one hand about um you know
killing somebody and on the other hand
they're saying that the person who
proposed The Killing that person
deserves a Nobel Peace Prize for what
they're doing but but they're very very
supportive to each other and again it's
for for a good reason we they're lacking
this this support and
at some point in the book I I recommend
to
hug conspiracy theorists and you know
the reality is that um I personally have
ostracized people before I did this
research one of my favorite sentences to
people who started in my view lose touch
with reality was to ask what is the
color of the sky in your world and I
thought it was funny but the people who
I said it to thought it was offensive I
thought it was a little funny not very
funny and they thought it was very
offensive and you know I think that
unintentionally I ostracize people right
the the process that you know what we
what we think about should should happen
between people of respect and listening
and understanding the causes and the
mechanism and so on um it's so hard it's
so hard to take somebody that has these
opinions and and hug them but but we
need
to this podcast is sponsored by Helix
sleep it's a pretty short list of things
you can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique match resses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like 5%
of people do the math for 100 night free
trial you can sleep on this thing for 3
months it will keep you cool don't just
take my word for it my kids seek out
this mattress in the house it's the
number one rated mattress picked by GQ
and Wired Magazine this mattress will
actually make you happier healthier and
more productive Helix is offering 20%
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners ERS go to
helixsleep.com yangang this is their
best offer yet and it won't last long
with Helix better sleep starts
[Music]
now yeah this book had a lot of uh
profundity to it um and it was personal
I mean reading it I was like oh my gosh
like what a ringer Dan has been through
it's nuts uh you know I mean I've I've
been through you know some uh like
adventures in social media but nothing
compared to to what um what you've been
through uh and I dare say that some of
these Dynamics are uh leading us to
disaster in various ways um um so you go
through this personal journey and then
through this research Journey uh
documenting various essentially facets
of human nature that LE lead people to
misbelief um so starting with emotional
cognitive personality social it's a very
powerful combination if you reflect on
it and I I dare say that there are tens
of millions of people I mean this is
normal in my mind this isn't like oh you
know and and I I by the way I totally
agree with uh you on not wanting to
ostracize folks and I try and avoid this
label of conspiracy theorist because uh
it's pejorative and also at this point
you got to say like you know some of
these iracy theories have totally been
true that's right because conspiracy
theory doesn't mean it's false yeah
completely um so at the end of this
journey that you document in the book um
you do try and strike notes of optimism
I think one thing you say is look guys
uh trust is really really important and
if you don't have it uh it ends up being
corrosive in all sorts of other ways so
so so look I I think that Humanity when
we discover that we've invented
something very bad it takes us a long
time to fix it and we need some will to
start attacking it think smoking and we
we have rules about freedom of
speech and we have rules about
misinformation but but misinformation
rules are really about you know a farmer
company cannot lie in their advertising
and people cannot give false testimony
in
court but outside of that we haven't
dealt with a problem but we didn't need
to to you know the The Funnel of
misbelief with all the elements is is a
weaponized system that we didn't have to
deal with because it was not that
powerful yeah but but now it's that
powerful you know we we never have to we
never had to worry about like a thousand
years ago we didn't worry about
biological
warfare now we really need to worry
about biological warfare and there's
lots of rules about limiting it because
even very few people can create
tremendous
damage and look it's not easy because we
all love freedom of speech all else
being equal it's better to have freedom
of speech than not we all want companies
to do whatever they want as long as
they're not hurting anybody but but in
this case I think we're starting to
understand the size of the damage and
imagine we did the following
calculation imagine that you we try to
calculate what is the loss of
trust brought
about
by social
media what is the cost to society you
know what is the cost in terms
of crime and police and tax payment and
medical adherence and you know you you
name it and mental health problems
anxiety and depression for sure I put
them on there mental health and and also
what is the chance that if there will be
a next pandemic that people would be
willing to to chip in and work
together what does it do to donations to
charity I mean imagine that we we we try
to um to quantify that I think it will
be a very very large number you know
this is why the lawsuit against Fox
right they basically said you know you
hurt our stock
price but I think I think here there's a
real tangible cost to society you know
it will be fascinating to try and
estimate the number but I think that no
matter how you estimate it it will be
very large uh I I would tend to agree
call that a negative externality um
though at this point this externality is
kind of central to American Life uh
unfortunately well you do have a number
of very very positive lessons in the
book and we mentioned some of them in
this conversation around uh around
trying to embrace ambiguity uh trust a
little more don't judge don't attack hug
someone who's going through sort of a
disengagement like don't don't think
that by turning on them you're going to
make anything better which you totally
won't uh and um you know these are
people that often are friends and family
members we we all have these people in
our lives that five years ago we looked
at them and we said we are the same and
now we look at them and we say you know
are we the same species like they they
feel broken to us we say you know they
look at the same information how could
it be that they come with such different
conclusions what's what's broken inside
that the transfer but but you know you
know the the book really explains
what what has changed it's not
broken and it's a slow process and it's
a difficult process and it's
comprehensive and the deeper people get
to it the deeper it would the longer it
would take to to get it back so we can
do things as
individuals companies can do things
right I think companies should encourage
respectful discussions with with
different opinions I think we could do
things help our friends ER when when
they we see their in needs in our in our
family and then the things to do is
society governments should have H plans
on how to regain
trust yeah Amen to that Dan I know
there's a a lot of rebuilding that needs
to be done in many ways your book uh I
think is an instrument towards empathy
towards greater empathy where if someone
looks at someone with a differing uh
opinion or perspective on something
let's say whether the election was
stolen you look at it be like oh um but
then you know like uh thanks to your
work it it you can see that it's deeply
human for people to arrive in different
places even based upon some of the same
information Dan Arelli new book
misbelief what makes rational people
believe irrational things remember again
that's rational people believing
irrational things uh congratulations on
this how can people keep up with you and
your work best place is my website
dani.com d n a r
i.com and I try to post everything there
fantastic please follow Dan he'll make
you smarter also note for someone
watching the video uh so uh Dan used to
shave and then um when he didn't shave
he found a lot of empathy with folks who
had experienced injury uh he got many
notes commending him and he said you
know what this is actually
uh who I am and uh let Let's uh be
honest with the world and has found a
lot of um kinship and fellowship uh
through that gesture yeah thanks for
mentioning
[Music]
it